jean marie belliard la douceur la grande
mais qu'il est génial organisé un
casting
ces neuf pas usé tout ça c'est bien et
on devrait booster émirats qu'on essaye
de les cacher parce que jésus oui ça
pourrait faire de l'ombre à jésus vous
imaginez les conséquences avec la
musique d'audiard fils la fille tu as vu
jolies filles j'ai 15 jours avant le
tournage parce que la lumière qu'ils
avaient envisagé les oui et non ça
allait pas été la chose dit elle était
pas gentil et le titre est aujourd'hui
les gens ils vont croire qu'elle n'a pas
voulu mais parce qu'on croit c'est ce
que les gens vont d'abord et bah c'est
pas ça d'ailleurs la preuve j'ai paniqué
l'autre n'ont plus l'usagé prime après
une tournée dans le bain à l'égard de sa
famille à son frère plus encadrer cela
m'est le plus c'est bien beau début on
voulait une belle fille on a eu un
boudin mais elle est que je dis tout le
temps que je l'invite plateau non elle
est jolie gentil aimable à la dé
bonnichon une bouche de mes roues et où
elle a tout pour réussir dans la vie
ouais j'ai posté question ma question
c'est qu'est-ce que c'est original cette
idée de faire une fable qu'on ne donnait
pas tu vois regard c'est bien c'est
parce qu'on avait dit que tu dirais ski
d'origine je crois que c'est contraire
je crois que c'est pas original j'ai à
dire et c'est plus original que
l'origine celle inverse d'original mon
film celle inverse d'un événement c'est
un film sympa
vas-y l'usta d'amour le fond est bon
c'est pour les gosses lemay la méchante
cruella et meurt alors elle tue elle
meurt dans la même vie
elle est même pardonné pour sa vie
d'après pour te dire donc nous on
fabrique des gros méchants pourri on
prend un gros gentil pas répéter la
gueule aux méchants on exacerbe le monde
extérieur et ce film s'adresse plus au
coeur de chacun de ses conseils et il
peut très bien ne pas marché du tout
avoir et à la gaumont bas ils auront
perdu 30 millions puis de celles qui
vont se libérer pour son fils mercredi
projette une salle de trafic d'influencé
normalement et ça non mais normalement
on craint vraiment dit elle a pu savez
comme il ya des gens qui sont venus
signer le livre de monica levinsky aux
galeries lafayette non 250
ouais et alors c'est beaucoup rien du
tout à fait rien comment heureusement
que ils font tous plus là druon imaginer
un jour
rap et d'intégrateurs t'imagines on a
mis tout le monde personne pour diriger
le monde sait faire signer un bouquin
par un taille-crayon franches le film
qui sort le 14 qu'il avait une bonne
mine que de l'époque peu changé moi j'ai
vu aux galeries lafayette mais ils
continuent là elle était encore au
printemps et au bhv la semaine prochaine
mondial moquette sept jours des signes
pas il fait une tache
je vous l'avais bien aujourd'hui même
s'il a ajouté la maman tout de suite ah
ben c'est génial
regarde alors vous dites j'ai peur alors
en plus il met le paquet c'est
pratiquement du chantage affectif il dit
j'ai peur
[ __ ] j'ai une question de vie ou de
mort donc on pense qu'ils pourraient en
russie des gens tu ne dis pas comme ça
je dis tout mon coeur d'un film
non j'ai dit c'est la réussite oullins
succès de ce film n'a aucune importance
pour moi c'est juste une question de vie
ou de mort a dit comme ça ça devient
drôle oui c'est vrai c'est beaucoup plus
drôle